[Música]
volvemos a hablar de la economía del
mundo en directo' américa y por supuesto
de la mano de daniela a blandón danny
bienvenida nuevamente vamos a hablar de
argentina porque suben las tasas de
interés en ese país así de raúl muy
buenos días de nuevo una de las
herramientas más poderosas que tienen
los bancos centrales para combatir la
inflación son precisamente los tipos de
interés ya que subiendo los
desincentivan de alguna manera el
consumo y argentina es un caso muy
particular el costo de vida creció más
del 55 por ciento interanual en marzo un
ritmo mucho más acelerado que los otros
países de la región y esto hace que sus
tasas de interés también sean bastante
altas tras conocer el dato de inflación
el banco central en la se elevó en 2,5
puntos porcentuales hasta el 47 por
ciento anual cuando en otros países como
colombia o chile son de menos del 6%
danny y en chile como ustedes lo estaba
hablando hace un proyecto para un nuevo
retiro anticipado de las pensiones
continúan en ese país con esto que sería
el cuarto retiro ya ha habido tres
durante la pandemia y como ha sucedido
desde el primer retiro que se dio a
mediados 2020 no hay un solo proyecto
sobre la mesa sino dos en los que avanza
la cámara de diputados- ambos prevén que
se pueda extraer hasta un 10% de los
ahorros pero uno de ellos garantiza la
entrega de casi sin condiciones como el
gobierno no estuvo de acuerdo porque
cree que eso tiene un efecto
inflacionario porque pone más dinero en
los bolsillos de los ciudadanos pues lo
que hizo fue presentar una propuesta
alternativa esta consiste en que el
dinero solamente se pueda usar en casos
específicos como por ejemplo pago de
pensiones alimentarias y deudas de
servicios públicos básicos salud o
créditos hipotecarios para primera
vivienda por ahora raúl la segunda
iniciativa está teniendo más acogida
aunque hay que recordar que en diciembre
ya se había hundido un proyecto parecido
y lo cierto es que se han retirado en
total hasta el momento 55 mil millones
de dólares danny la industria la belleza
también está sufriendo los estragos de
lo que estamos viviendo en ucrania esta
guerra que pasa y señor por lo menos en
europa en donde los fabricantes de
perfumes y cosméticos se enfrentan
escasez de insumos a medida que la
invasión rusa de ucrania agrega más
interrupciones a las cadenas de
suministro en esa que es una industria
de más de medio billón de dólares al año
y cuya demanda viene en ascenso y es que
los productores usan alcohol derivado de
granos y remolachas orgánicas para hacer
perfumes y también aceites de semilla de
girasol para hacer cosméticos todos
estos cultivos son clave en estos dos
países que están en guerra además la
crisis energética también ha disparado
los precios del vidrio y del papel que
se usan para fabricar los frascos y los
empaques rígidos de lujo como si fuera
poco hay estudios que señalan que desde
que inició el conflicto los precios de
producción han subido entre un 25 y un
30% y al final pagamos los consumidas
así están y vamos a ver qué va a pasar
entonces indicadores económicos en
europa el mercado opera con leves
ganancias a la espera de la reunión del
banco central europeo en la que podría
haber decisiones sobre tasas de interés
las acciones asiáticas subieron
mayormente después de una muy buena
jornada
en wall street y hay noticias en wall
street también daniela para seguir esa
cola con la que usted está hablando de
lo que pasa en wall street claro que sí
porque el dueño de tesla elon musk hizo
lo que se conoce como una oferta es
hostil es decir no solicitada por sus
accionistas por 43.000 millones de
dólares esto para quedarse con twitter y
sacarla del mercado accionario el hombre
más rico del mundo está ofreciendo un 54
por ciento más de lo que vale la empresa
este jueves que es unos 37 mil millones
de dólares y la red social por lo está
analizando 37 mil millones de dólares
nada menos si la cifra del día cuál es
pues mire raúl un dólar vale hoy 85 81 5
rublos y le traigo a colación esta cifra
porque si bien es un nivel que se asoma
a lo que era antes de lo que iniciará la
pandemia el rublo está perdiendo fuerza
esta semana porque es posible que el
gobierno de vladímir putin relaje aún
más las medidas de control de capital
que había impuesto para que no se
fugaran los dólares del país y es que
actualmente un exportador ruso que
reciba divisas tiene que verlas dentro
de los tres días siguientes como una
manera de mantenerlas en circulación y
así limitar la volatilidad del rubro
danny pues que esté con nosotros
entonces para analizar este tema lo que
está pasando en rusia en materia
económica esto con nuestro segundo
invitado del día
[Música]
en nuestro invitado del día vamos a
analizar lo que ocurre dentro de rusia
la economía de ese país cómo viven los
ciudadanos en medio de todas estas
sanciones y parte del bloqueo por los
países de occidente en respuesta a esta
guerra que inició el presidente ruso
vladimir putin el pasado 24 de febrero
ya son 50 días de guerra con sanciones
sanciones y más sanciones para ello por
supuesto está conmigo en el estudio
daniel hablando en nuestra periodista
experta en economía y quiero saludar en
este momento nuestro segundo invitado él
es ignacio montesdeoca periodista y
escritor ignacio gracias por estar con
nosotros en economía en pues en directo
américa de france 24 cómo están viviendo
entonces actualmente los rusos la
población civil en medio de todas estas
sanciones en la vida cotidiana hablemos
del día a día
qué tal buenos días gracias por la
invitación y cómo están viviendo los
rusos los rusos están empezando a sentir
en este momento y cada vez más las
consecuencias de la guerra en sus
bolsillos es decir todo lo que la lo que
la propaganda no les permite conocer del
frente de combate les está entrando por
los bolsillos de la manera de un
incremento en la inflación una caída en
el empleo y por sobre todo una serie de
restricciones al consumo que se hacen
acá es más evidente en la medida que se
agotan los stocks
disponibles antes de la granja
bueno se habla mucho de como el
occidente depende de rusia en materia
energética no directamente producción
agrícola pero como depende también rusia
del resto del mundo que le provee el
resto del mundo este país
exacto
pagamos
vamos a cerrar las cifras para para
empezar a hablar en el 75% de los
productos no alimentarios que consume
rusia proviene en el exterior y en ese
65 el 60 y el 75 el 60 proviene en el
occidente es decir no es que rusia le
vende solamente materias primas a
occidente a cambio consume una cantidad
inmensa para su economía de productos
occidentales que son los que llevan
mayor nivel de elaboración de manera que
las restricciones están pegando en el
consumo de bienes que rusia no puede
reemplazar desde
textil a un celular y
la vida cotidiana y a veces uno hablar
de economía como una como algo
etéreo teórico pero en la vida cotidiana
y uno está en contacto con centro de
reducción nos están diciendo y empezamos
a notar que no podemos reemplazar son
básicas para no solamente para el
confort sino para la supervivencia
claro aterrizamos ahora inácio la
inflación lo conversamos ahora con
daniela blandón el caso de américa
latina pero estos 50 días que lleva ya
la guerra y con sanciones sanciones y
más sanciones ya se habla de un sexto
paquete por parte por ejemplo para
hablar de un bloque de los países de la
unión europea cómo afecta la inflación y
qué tanto ha aumentado en rusia en estos
últimos días
y la última medición de último 1.17 lo
cual está elevando la proyección a de 18
el año más optimista que se tenía el mes
pasado más que significaba 30 y ahora es
más optimista arranca en 25 y termina en
40 y las proyecciones de estaciones
tienen que ver también con que con estas
nuevas sanciones lo que se está pensando
y esto
empezando a hablar es si occidente va a
empezar a sancionar a terceros países o
empresas que comercian con russians sin
que necesariamente ser rusas con lo cual
podría estrechar aún más el cerco
económico sobre ese país
y esto tendría consecuencias aún más
severas sobre la economía
señor ignacio cómo se vive el día a día
ya es decir hay desabastecimiento en los
en las tiendas la gente de pronto no
tiene con qué comprar como el cs día a
día
bueno esto me lo comentaba que empiezan
a faltar productos tan sencillos como
uno
para lavarse el cabello o un repuesto
para una computadora desde empieza a
haber una
alarma y una pérdida de confianza en la
economía que bueno se vivió los primeros
días cuando una corrida se retiraron
2400 millones grandes del sistema porque
la gente se hace con efectivo pero
también se empezó a vivir en él
en materias primas muy básicas en el
empezó con el acaparamiento de azúcar me
contaban en rusia que de pronto todos se
empezaron a buscar azúcar y ustedes
dirán que tiene que ver bueno pasa que
el azúcar se usa para las conservas es
una costumbre muy rusa empezó a faltar
aceite porque los rusos dijeron bueno si
si en la cuenta agrícola hay nada de
observa falta el aceite los rusos
empiezan a vivir la vida cotidiana con
una idea de verdad economía de guerra
está mermando en mucho la confianza del
consumidor sobre el futuro de la
economía y esto va a impactar en el día
a día y de alguna manera está poniendo
un manto de duda sobre lo que podría
como podrían llegar a responder la
población frente a las medidas internas
que está tomando por fin porque todos
sabemos que la economía es una ciencia
exacta pero en última instancia también
depende de la
produciendo consumidores empresarios
sobre la propia economía ignacio también
hablamos de un tema muy importante y es
del desempleo como está ahora el
desempleo en rusia recordemos que ya son
decenas de empresas las que se han
retirado del territorio ruso como parte
de este boicot de occidente para tratar
de decirle al presidente vladimir putin
pues para la guerra para que todo vuelva
digamos a la normalidad en su territorio
como ha afectado este retiro de empresas
a las personas que trabajaban en ellas
como que tanto ha subido a lo mejor el
desempleo en rusia
eso es muy importante para entender cómo
ser rusia en rusia el desempleo llegó al
59 por ciento de su nivel no se deriva
de la guerra de crimea en el 2014
cuál es el problema con el retiro de las
multinacionales de la unesco solo con el
retiro hubo 125 mil puestos de trabajo
menos ahora
hay un millón de puestos de trabajo que
dependen de las multinacionales muchas
de estas empresas se retiraron pero
siguen pagando los sueldos en tanto se
resuelve la situación si no se resuelve
estas 125 mil empleos que se perdieron
se van a multiplicar porque van a dejar
de pagar esas plantillas que a veces
siguen pagando a la espera de una
solución pero además que el retiro de
las multinacionales tienen un efecto
multiplicador porque uno sabe que cuando
hablamos de relación hablan de l'oréal
pero al se retira pero la verdad con él
se pierden entre 4.000 y 7.000 empleos
pero qué sucede l'oréal tenía una serie
de proveedores dentro de rusia entonces
el cálculo sobre los 125 mil empleos que
se perdieron de manera directa abarca
otro millón de por una fuerza de trabajo
de 50 millones con otro millón estadios
trabajo porque ya no se pueden hacer
negocios con empresas que se retiraron
entonces ese 5.9 por ciento es altísimo
para reducida
qué son tres millones más de empleados
de desempleados se da además en las en
las regiones urbanas y suburbanas que es
donde tiene el mayor peso político
pública entonces es un problema de
desempleo también se convierte en un
problema político que se va a
incrementar en la medida que las
sanciones sigan actuando sobre la tasa
de desempleo también no solamente el
desempleo sino la pérdida del poder
adquisitivo hay estudios que dicen que
antes los hogares gastaban un 20 por
ciento de sus ingresos en alimentos
ahora gasta en un 40% en alimentos como
lidiar con esa situación lo que está
haciendo el gobierno para afrontar esta
situación
si hubo el poder adquisitivo y esto es
plato duro si bien la inflación subió un
11.3 en 1.13
desde que empezó la guerra los alimentos
subieron un 30% y algunos alimentos
mucho más 30% presionamos el caso de
shampoo pero en el caso del té
no subas de hasta el ciento por ciento
en el caso del azúcar más del 30 por
ciento entonces
ahora aquí en lo que está aquí lo que
propone es en fin propone el compre
nacional o sea reemplazar esas
importaciones por productos nacionales
pero esto tiene un problema tiene un
prueba que es muy severo que es que una
cosa es refinar azúcar otra costumbre o
si se quieren moler el país o el trigo
para hacer
la vida pero para fabricar productos un
poco más elaborados hace falta no
solamente en bar ciudad claro también
know-how y maquinarias esas maquinarias
que producen están repuestos necesitan
la hoja y cuando se retiran las
multinacionales y de
retirarse lo causa que tiene esa
eficiencia productiva con lo cual
producir cada cada bien cuesta un
poquito más eso contribuye a la
inflación pero además a largo plazo lo
que va a provocar es que ante la falta
de repuestos para ese una fábrica que
fabrica blisters para parar elementos
farmacéuticos como fábrica
en base al yogur eso va
esa máquina deja de funcionar porque hay
que entrenar también otras cosas no
estamos en los años 40 las máquinas son
muy complejas requieren chips requieren
circuitos requieren programas que con
las sanciones dejan de llegar a rusia sí
con lo cual los productos tienden a
encarecerse y te traslada de la
inflación ignacio gracias por su tiempo
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 gracias a mí como
siempre también por acompañarnos en
temas económicos nosotros continuamos
esto es directo